j'ai tombe tout de suite les temps sans
gagner ce combat pour me montrer à quel
point son supérieur si tu tombes pas
tout de suite témoin en victoire ici ces
deux maisons prestige tube est la tête
tu sert les clients commenté toujours la
même chose avec vous l'aimez loin pour
un bon cadre j'ai peut-être un melon
pêche mais aussi un groupe a proposé ce
match
mouais
et ont sauvé mais le mois
c'est peut-être aussi parce que t'as pas
oublier d'où tu viens
urs et si elle n'est pas pour nous pas
pour nos tables étaient bloqués en coin
24 donc ces paroles faut qu'ils perdent
4 kilos en quelques jours
temps
attendre je dois la pampa
il tord photo pat et s'est montrée
puisqu'il ya ce à cause de mes fringues
je pensais pas tirée jusque là je suis
plus en paix reste aux 36 combats
radiateur carreau
cette ville